Mike we're talking battlefield one now
we've seen the trailer new trailer we've
had a live stream today but you my
friend got to actually play battlefield
one I got to play it everyone we won
handily what did you actually play
conquest we played conquest mode which
is kind of your traditional you know
you're taking points across this pretty
big map this one was called San Quentin
scar in northern France you know there's
there's one points like in this old
dilapidated church one points in this
kind of little hamlet up to the
northwest one points up near this
windmill where this sniper was kind of
covering the whole time it feels very
much like older battlefields like 1942
battlefield to kind of you know these
huge maps these kind of like battles
that unfold differently they're not just
gonna be these harrowing firefights the
entire time although it is like you know
you you go in these farm houses close
quarters but then you come outside and
you're worried about sniper across the
map you get in an anti-tank cannon just
demolish the windmill he's in you just
destroy the cover artillery rains down
you crawl into a crater that it created
to wait out while your meta can get to
you there's all these like emergent
situations that happen that don't really
happen to call of duty anymore yeah
they're hinting at this game being very
similar to bad comfy to write with
destructive destructible environments
yeah and you earlier your tell you were
telling me yeah like a artillery shell
came down and created craters you like
then got in and used as cover yeah you
hear the whistle of the artillery shells
and then like I saw I thought I was dead
to my teammates died but also you know
like if my screens flashing red because
I my health is really low I call for a
medic and I crawl into one of the
craters that it just created on the
other side of this brick wall that it
also destroyed so I'm waiting and I can
hear the sound design is fantastic you
hear you can hear the bullets hitting
this like the bricks next to me and then
also just whizzing over my head I can
hear this tank shell trying to zero in
on me the whole time I was just like
kind of like what do I need to do in
this moment that can help my team and at
that point it just wasn't it was just
survived because I was in a capture
point yeah so just let me just sitting
in that crater whether i was actually
shooting back at the enemy or not didn't
matter i just needed to hold it down for
other people to get there in a tank
hopefully or an armored truck or maybe
even a strafing run from plane overhead
yeah speaking of vehicles did you get
hands on with any of them yeah so you
there are a couple points on the map
that if you own you can spawn right into
a vehicle there will be like a propeller
on the mini-map or a tank so i spawned
into an armored truck with someone and
every vehicle has designated rolls right
if you're driving the vehicle you're not
going to be firing the cannon if you're
in the side with a turret you're not
going to be firing the cannon I got into
one of the heavier tanks and I was kind
of you know I was doing the forward
mounted machine gun and then when you
reload it takes a while to reloads and
your kind of defenseless for a little
bit but then there's a guy with the
candidate who's reloading each
individual shell it's kind of like you
can also spawn into armored trucks when
they're on the map so I see my team
trying to take point F for example I
can't spawn there obviously it's not our
point but I see this armored truck
coming down along the path i spawned at
that I'm inside it and I'm with my team
going right for it awesome yeah um you
know I'm so surprised I really didn't
say the Zeppelin was gonna be
controllable but explained me the other
you mentioned like earlier to me about
the Zeppelin essentially having a role
not just as a vehicle but like as a face
in the given match yeah at first I was
kind of worried it's almost like the
rubber banding right when the one team
is losing they'll get the airship about
halfway through the I asked Alex
produced around the game Alex Crandall
when the airship will actually come into
play and he said they haven't gotten the
timing completely down sometimes they
halfway sometimes would be just like
this team's getting smoked they need
some sort of help but it is completely
pilot able I mean you have a the captain
steering it it's pretty slow but then
you have like I'm assuming I didn't
pilot it but I'm assuming he's the one
that's releasing these floods of bombs
then you have a turret caged in the back
of turkeys in the front a bunch along
the side so one of my teammates was
coming in on a biplane you know like
strafe and there was pretty slow aerial
combat from what I saw and it wasn't
able to spawn into a plane but he was
doing strafing runs along the side of
the blimp the airship as they're calling
it and it took about four seconds these
things are huge and the planes are like
slow enough to actually have this
methodical combat you start probably the
coolest part is a bunch of my teammates
were in a town like one of the last
points that we didn't have at the time
yeah three of us were in flat cannons
hitting the blimp other two are doing
strafing runs alongside of it tail
gunner was just hosing them we destroyed
it and this thing rained down and just
flatten the town
people who were inside it like the it
was still the framework of the shack
still existed but they were just utterly
destroyed by this thing I mean it's dead
like here ups into flames and then just
fall slowly so you it's it's cool
because you have time to get out of
there yeah if it's only like five
seconds so like a few my teammates like
in trucks like kid oh my god yup field
out back down the road it was it the
battlefield itself and the way the
ground deformed and the way the
destruction kind of fed into where you
were going what path you're gonna take
what vehicle you think would do best for
the job they just felt like so much like
you're constantly thinking but it's such
as like methodical pace that it's so
enticing just like just running to a
choke point having a sniper firing you
even if you can't see him with just like
exhilarating yeah moving on to weather
yeah um now this version I don't think
you you had any of the dynamic weather
they talked about and bread I don't know
what the specific algorithm is and when
it decides to do it but sometimes from
what I hear sometimes the weather will
affect it sometimes of the weather like
boggle Rowland sometimes it won't
sometimes play a match it'll be clear
sky at the whole time oh and Jerri it's
random like okay weather is but like I'm
I asked they didn't confirm is like so
I'm assuming that'll be like sand storms
right in the desert ones he's like maybe
for like this is kind of an on
confirmation thing but yeah fog will
roll in and that essentially just makes
the entire map close quarters you can
only see like 10 feet in front of you
snipers are gonna do anything planes
you're gonna have to be pretty careful
I'm not running into one of your
teammates right or you're just simply
avoiding attacking the ground and you're
just lying and just getting it to a
dogfight at the same time though the fog
could help out planes if you have like
four planes coming over the enemy's base
the flat Canada's can't see you so
you're pretty much getting behind their
lines it's the weather itself it just
feels like you know like you assume
they're gonna be like maybe Blizzard
maps because there's going to be some of
my cold weather maps from there telling
us but you assume like you know like
these things are gonna just completely
change up like between the destruction
the weather how many different vehicles
there are you're getting promoted during
the match so you can take on a tank
officer or a pilot role Oh further buffs
in these vehicles just the differences
among each map and how though unfold
just seemed like this game has a lot of
longevity yeah I'm really excited to
play more of it that's awesome um you
got to ask more about this there's a new
game mode called operations getting kind
of lightly touch on what that is exactly
sure so the operations themselves like
the titular things you'll be attacking
team defending team and it'll be like
kind of like a regular
match that you're playing at first you
but except the attacking team has all
these like minor almost like side
missions to be doing to push the enemy
the defensive team back okay and while I
asked him they haven't confirmed what
those will be I asked if it'll be like
okay will you be like I'm escorting this
vehicle or like moving this package to
another area or defending this explosive
and he said like yeah and from what it
sounds like there's gonna be a lot of
different kind of side quests like that
factoring into it the offensive team if
they succeed at getting past the
defensive team and pushing them back the
match will that game will end and then
you can get out if you want you can quit
but if you stay in it'll continue on a
different map so it'll just keep
building on itself and now it'll keep
going until the defensive team makes the
stand the thing that interests me and
this is that you can the matches will be
different time to time because you're
having these different side missions and
fold these different operations so it
won't always be like take this objective
hold it for a while until you can clear
out the enemy team sometimes it'll be
like you know theoretically sometimes
will be like destroyed this Armada tanks
or something or like demolish this
building so we can get a better sight
line or something like that just like
these cool little things that I kak chua
Lee might technically help you in the
battle feeding it's like the story of
each match cuz that's like what i love
about battlefield you come away from
these matches with crazy stories I was
telling you about how i flatten that
windmill and then the sniper killed one
of my buddies so you know the truck
comes roaring around the side gives you
cover while you can run to a machine gun
he chose it like that's what I love
about battlefield and I'm hoping
operations can kind of deliver that feel
that the conquest mode seems to be
harkening back to as well awesome a lot
of stuff going on man it's super excited
for battlefield a battlefield fans well
thanks Mike and for all of you watching
stay tuned and subscribe to our YouTube
channel and get more battlefield one
content one more thanks Mike thanks
you